i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
[Music]
welcome to fearless i'm your host tim
ferriss and on this stage we'll be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all different types to uncover the
specific tactics they've used to
overcome doubt tackle some of their
hardest decisions and ultimately succeed
on their own terms so imagine yourself a
founding member of one of the most
successful rock bands of all time what
happens when you break up
for many that might be the end of the
story but for my guest tonight was just
getting started with no prior experience
he went on to score films for francis
ford coppola and oliver stone composed
for ballet and opera and even take
pilgrimages to africa where he played
drums with hungry lions i'm not kidding
he's a founding member of the police a
member of the rock and roll hall of fame
and for the last three decades he's been
one of rolling stone's top 10 drummers
of all time
please welcome musician master and
madman stuart copeland
[Music]
all right it's so nice to see you again
it's so nice to see you again and we're
gonna have a lot of time to explore all
sorts of fun stuff i thought we would
start with a video so let's take a video
so you guys know exactly who we have in
front of us
[Music]
one of the only two drum solos i've ever
done in my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the weirdest thing about that
performance there letterman huge you
know thing and the i played with her
band that took me decades of writing
music and practicing and doing my route
to get up all this skill but at the end
of the thing
i threw my sticks over there
and that was the big hit of the
appearance
which is an illustration of a point that
it's the dumb [ __ ]
never mind never mind the decades of
dedication to music and craft and
everything else
it's the dumb [ __ ] practice throwing
your sticks kids yeah so you said while
we were watching that that this was one
of only two drum solos you've ever done
yes i i don't really believe in drum
solos even though i loved them when i
was 14.
uh they're real hard work it's usually
just a chance for the band to sell
merchandise
um
so this is one of them it was letterman
they're doing drums the other
was in the wilds of africa you see oh
yes how did that
come together how did that eve come into
reality somebody had the bright idea
of me going to africa in search of
rhythm and american music because of
course our one of our most profound
uh cultural characteristics in our
country is american music the origins of
which are of course africa you found a
very receptive audience for your second
season well we were out there with a
film crew and we had no idea what we're
doing some of the best things happen
when you don't know what you're doing
and then a buddy of ours a khashoggi
family a
billionaire or arabic family owned a
ranch
near mount kenya
and
so we went out there and they had
giraffes and all this stuff like that so
we shot everything and one of the things
they had was a pride of lions he said
hey
let's put the drum set with the lions
and there stuart will be playing drums
and the lions will be new so they built
this chicken wire cage
it's not lion wire so we have to festoon
the cage with meat to make them
interested in the cage because otherwise
they're just taking a nap and you know
who cares that's not a shot so we had to
put meat around there and eventually i
fear thump like that and it's one guy
big guy right there holy crap and then
the other one's reaching under the cage
and like the drums going there and i can
see this arm i think holy [ __ ]
that was the badassest drum solo i ever
did in my life
it's like uh
it's like audio bear spray there you go
yeah yeah well you know their ears are
not equipped my snare drum is loud
it will bring a bird down out of the sky
and so those lions
you know they got big teeth they got a
lot of hair there are some claws that
they can do some damage but i got a
snare drum made out of chrome
so as it so happens
uh i've only done two drum solos in my
life and so let's let's watch one of
them
[Music]
great
ah you're getting power mad oh you could
feel the power rising up in your loins
you're a primate an alpha male the great
silverback making a great noise because
you've got your crash and your cake
landing hard
so that video is actually from the first
day the first time we ever met and one
of the things that so impressed me about
stewart was a you saw the machine at
action right i mean just incredible but
you're an extremely good teacher
well the result are you going to show
the results i'm not going to show the
result but i'll tell them so i think it
was totally rocked so for finally now
four or five days later i had to get up
in front of a sold out audience for
foreigner and drum
hot-blooded in front of a completely
sold-out crowd
uh and that was just such a tremendous
experience for me and i wanted to
actually read a quote of yours that i
think
ties into how music for me in that
moment went from being something very
intimidating and sterile to very fun so
this is from stewart's book strange
things happen
that's the great thing about music if
you played it it's correct the worst
musical train wreck hurts absolutely no
one it's all part of the show in fact
it's how we get to the great stuff
there's no penalty for skating on the
edge or throwing ourselves off the cliff
so we do
and
this seems like it's it's true of music
it's true for a lot of life can you
provide any more context it's not true
of uh
paragliding
it's not true of
skiing
right definitely don't want to literally
hurl yourself on a cliffs uh
but
when you are trying to say introduce
someone to music how do you think about
doing it playing music that is introduce
somebody playing music it is that thing
of throwing yourself off a cliff and not
judging yourself that's the most
important thing is to hit a drone hey it
makes a sound cool or sit on the piano
just hit some notes and just listen to
the that doesn't have to be mozart
music was designed as a campfire
experience as
you know i've thought long and hard over
the decades about what is music for it's
obviously for something we are evolved
through all culture all history music
has been there
it must have
a purpose a behavioral purpose
and a couple theories i have one is uh
social cohesion and i feel that in my
travels across the fourth world you feel
that music bonds a community so that's
very important but the other really
important thing is sex
and you may laugh salaciously
but it's true that particularly for
teenagers and young adults music is the
key to sex it is the key to
body language that would be unacceptable
without music playing
the things people do on the dance floor
can you imagine without music oh my god
and so music uh it unlocks the door so
that we can uh
so that we can show our genetic wares to
each other and what pelvic thrusting has
to do with genetic superiority i don't
know
but music does seem to have a very
important function and so you ask how do
you
bring somebody who's not a musician or
how to explain music well it's just pick
up an instrument and make a sound and
listen to the beauty of it
and that's enough but there's a commun
communication part as well and i believe
um that although i personally
personally am a great beneficiary of
specialization in our evolved society i
get to play the music and you get to
listen but i think that's not how it was
evolved for our hunter-gatherer
societies way back and you know before
civilization i think it was something
that we all did together and indeed when
you travel to the small indigenous
communities they all make it there isn't
specialization he's not the musician
they're not when it comes to religion
and magic yes he's the shame and and you
believe but music is something they all
do together you don't have to be
um
a super musician to really enjoy playing
music where did you grow up can you
describe for us
your early childhood my daddy was both
jazz musician and c.i.a man
this is serious
uh and so i was born in virginia uh
alexandria virginia which is a suburb of
the c.i.a
uh but my dad
i think that's your dad and uh
but my daddy was away on business
he was in cairo egypt installing a
dictator and so that meant that i was
shipped over there
when i was two months old to cairo
and from there to beirut and i didn't
get back to america until i was 18.
so that whole time i'm in the weird zone
of the world an american i went to an
american school i'm america's everything
great was american so i've always been
hyper aware of being america most of you
here as americans you know you're not
identified as an american every day but
i was i was the american kid
and so that instills a strange kind of
patriotism in a weird sort of way i'm
sure
did you at what point did you know your
dad was in the ca it was from the very
beginning or no no
in fact my brother miles came home from
school one day and says dad
are you a spy
to which my father responded who wants
to know
[Laughter]
what did you guys think he did up to
that point my mother used to said years
later my mother said you could always
tell the spies
by the trivial nature of their
conversation they wouldn't you know spy
is the one guy in the room who's not
talking politics
and uh and one of my father's best
friends was kim philby a british double
agent and one of my friends was harry
his son harry philby were kind of
parallel families and one day their
daddy disappeared
double agent meaning kgb as well as one
day their daddy disappeared true blue
english mi5
uh blue blood disappeared two weeks
later he showed up in moscow he had been
a double agent all along he was one of
my father's best friends and they knew
there was a leak the british had a leak
and there it's got to be philby it's got
to be kim philby and then he just it was
getting hot for him he disappeared so
that's what harry philby had to deal
with with spy daddy at least my spy
daddy wasn't a double agent you know
what what drew you to music initially
was it just the family influence or
something else yeah it was something i
could do
um and it was you know
listening to it you know everybody is
beguiled by music they were all the same
and the re you know my father he was a
jazz trumpet player i've still got his
trumpet uh
and he put all these musical instruments
in the house for the sibling you know
but one by one the sibling to pick them
up you know uh
you know but i came along there they all
were and they just came to me and i'd
pick them up and i'd
break them soon you know
uh but still
and so my father spotted the
unmistakable trait
of a musician
which is the kid will not stop
you know if you have your daughter and
you're sending her to violin lessons or
piano lessons then if you ever have to
remind that girl
isn't it time for your practice
and forget it forget it if i go find
something else for this this kid to do
uh if in fact
do you think you could stop playing for
a minute okay now you got a musician in
the family
you know that's how you can tell and
i just don't know what it's like not to
have
an a desire to pick up that thing and
hit it or make it make a sound somehow
or do you remember your first gig i do
at the american embassy beach club and
we played the kinks
and uh animals house of the rising sun
little james brown of course
um
and
that really
a very important moment because i was
the youngest of four and my older
brother ian was the cool kid
and he was
the cool kid in school he you know had a
motorcycle
and um
the band needed a drummer
the drummer kid went back to the states
but his drums were still there and so
ian obviously we need ian in the band
because he's the coolest kid in school
it's ian's on ian's the drummer but he
couldn't actually do it anyhow he got me
in the band so there i am i've joined
the black knights i'm hearing i'm at the
beach club and i can hear two 15 year
old girls talking now for 12 year old 15
year old girls are just
the dream of my you know
of you know the unclimbable mountain
yeah you know
and uh just so far beyond oh no no don't
eat don't even that'll never you know
and i could hear these two 15 year old
girls talking about wow the black
knight's got a cool a new drummer gru or
hep or whatever words they use in those
days you know girl who is he it's ian
copeland's kid brother
ian has a brother
[Laughter]
[Music]
and so they're talking about this
mythical being who is now the drummer in
the black knights who's ian's kid
brother and they're talking wow is he
cute and they're talking about this
person and they're constructing in their
mind they're creating a person and i'm
literally there i'm like three years
away from puberty like
i was just a little again they're
talking about me
very important moment in a musical
career
what
influence or lasting impact did that
upbringing have on
your life for your later tradeocumen
what have you brought with you if
anything from that culturally yeah um
the music
has a real
important thing
which is that by some
accident cultural accident it has the
same dropkick as reggae
the the mechanics of the the arabic beat
the baladi rhythms
that is actually mechanically
foundationally the same building blocks
of the reggae beat
which is the emphasis on three of the
bar
and the absence of one
three four
three four two three four nothing two
three you know and
growing up with that
kind of almost you know
part of my genes you know genetic
structure musically surrounded by that
rhythm and then the clash had the
brilliant idea of attempting to actually
play reggae and they did a track
called police and thieves
and ironically
the police came along and thieved that
idea
but uh
we had a secret weapon
which was the ballady rhythms of the of
the lebanese mountains so when did
curved air enter the picture well curved
air was the band that led me uh away
from finishing my college education i
got myself in as a tour manager
and so i was the tour manager of curved
air cut two few years later and i'm
married to the singer and i'm in the
band
i think that's a game of thrones move
well it was a wonderful circumstance you
know i have you know we have three fine
sons together and uh it's a wonderful
thing i want to pull up
a few letters
that you sent to music magazines and uh
using different handwriting styles
spellings and stationery
uh so we're gonna pull up we're gonna
pull up these are letters that he sent
to
music magazines while being the drummer
of curved air keep in mind so the first
one starts dear sirs
dear series i recently had the exquisite
joy of experiencing a curved air concert
and was most impressed by the
exceptional talent of their new drummer
that's kind of highbrow kind of hybrid
so the next one music aficionado not to
be thought the same person yeah dear
sounds
curved air are brilliant with a why
what's the drummer's name
next to whom it may concern wow
me and some mates went to see curved air
at the incredible especially the new
drummer
see these boots
you're pulling them up by your own
goddamn bootstraps you know
and i'd mail these letters in you know
we'd play skunthorpe and and
you don't want to know okay all right
it sounds like a lord as we were leaving
scunthorpe i'd hit the mailbox hey guys
i just got to take a piss for a second i
go and hit the mailbox
and different handwriting different
different literal little you know
different styles
and that was the first time i got my
name in print thank you very much
you know
yeah why wait for attention when you can
grab it
i learned that all by the way i learned
that from my father
how did you first meet sting
it was a stormy night
[Laughter]
we had a night off in newcastle and the
local journalist phil sutcliffe took me
to see the local hero band playing at
the local college the first thing you
noticed was a golden ray of sunshine a
lighting upon the brow
of the golden one
his name was fred
just kidding that was sting
and no he could play bass and sing and
that was what was impressed me about it
and i was i already had the idea of the
police i had the name uh the logo i had
a manifesto even and uh you know this
idea i just didn't have any guys in the
band except me um so i saw this guy and
i wanted it to be a three piece so a few
months later i was actually saying well
let me actually get this thing i want to
get that bass player up in newcastle so
i called up the journalist and asked him
phil sutcliffe to give me the telephone
number you know that bass player you
introduced me to
sting
uh
and he said oh no i'm not giving you
this number i know what you're doing
down there in london you're into this
punk thing aren't you and you want to
ruin our newcastle band and i'm not
giving you the number you know he hangs
up i hang up and i'm half an hour like
wait wait a minute it's like
you know i call him back and hello it's
his girlfriend uh phil's not here and uh
well i just want to get a number of that
baseball okay let me look at his phone
book i'll go get it
so she goes
so she goes off and gets the number
brings it back gives me the number and i
thought oh [ __ ] now i need a guitarist
sting and i we actually earned our
living doing sessions as a rhythm
section and we show up at the studio to
do a session
and a guitarist walks in who is like way
above our thing this is a fancy session
triple scale guitarist absolutely the
top session guy in london the name of
andy summers
and a few weeks later i ran into andy in
london we were both getting off
the underground together and hey it's
you hey it's you hey lisa stewart
let's have a coffee and he pulls me a
sign
stuart you and that bass player
you've got something
but you need me in the band and i accept
now i i i tell this story with love and
admiration in my heart for andy summers
he is a guy who
is that and i you know he he gets
uncomfortable when i tell that story but
it so encapsulates the power of andy
summers up until that point i supplied
the songs they were crap songs three
minute fake punk songs
they hate me
you know you know punk stuff you know
and the rules of punk were actually very
strict thou shalt not write a song over
three minutes thou shalt not write a
song about love thou shalt only write
about being pissed off you know
and uh the dress code was very strict
nobel bottoms short hair uh the hairdo
was critical the rules of punk were
extremely strict the rules the rebels
had a lot of roles exactly
funny thing that isn't it yeah
but
now
sting had an actual musician to work
with
and suddenly you know he comes up with a
song i think it was born in the 50s
which actually had some chord inversions
and stuff as soon as i wow that's great
let's do that and one by one these songs
started coming out which were pretty
wouldn't have been possible until
sting and andy you know andy could play
the stuff that he could write and he
sting himself had no idea that he could
write a hip-hop song he had never
attempted to he'd never really seen
himself in that role
but the punk world of three-minute songs
the discipline all that discipline of
all those rules
it's something clicked and he suddenly
out of nowhere started to write these
great songs
at that point in time in your heads or
maybe just in your head what did success
for that band look like what was
three years later incremental um some of
the milestones were not the big ones but
they felt like the big ones you know one
milestone was the marquee club in london
where everybody played there the who
played there there just it was the club
it was like the whiskey uh in london it
was just the history of that place and
um and there was a hierarchy
uh the bottom of the hierarchy is you're
supporting on a weekend because they
don't you know anybody can you know the
weekend they're going to do business
anyway and then the next is supporting
on the weekday because that's the
toughest thing you got to have a little
bit of a draw then when you headline on
a thursday you are king of the world
we're headlining the marquee on
thursday
and so uh that you know headlining the
marquee on a thursday was a big deal and
we felt like we
yeah we're getting somewhere yeah baby
and but we still weren't getting
anywhere
we were still starving and we were still
written off by the press and somebody
had the bright my brother miles this
time had the bright idea of let's go to
america
so we did and punk
hadn't failed here because the sex
pistols came over and sucked they bombed
and the word punk just did not resonate
in america in the same way that it did
in england it had wrong associations it
just didn't catch for it so they erased
the american record again erased all the
punkarama the pro you know the on the
album which had all these pictures of us
in leather jackets and looking hostile
and everything got rid of all that and
airbrushed the american edition of our
first album is airbrushed so we looked
12.
uh and we came to america and
club by club city by city we worked our
way every city was fighting the battle
all over again man but we did and
finally um i guess
so along the way there were these
milestones while we were on tour in
america we heard
that we had a hit in england you know uh
that got on the bbc and so you know i
guess a big one was shea stadium
because that's for english band
even though i'm american that was an
english band
playing shea stadium is the beatles
that means your beatle
that means you've conquered america
that's official now you've conquered
america when you play shea stadium and
not only for yourselves but for the
british press corps the british
england
is conquering america
when an english man plays shea stadium
and so it's like a national thing and uh
the whole whole england gets excited
about it so i guess that would have been
a pretty cool milestone too were you
nervous before that gig
i i guess you would call it nerves
is there anything you did did you have a
pre-game ritual or anything like that oh
artists of all kinds have many
pregame rituals
and they evolve and they emerge one day
you have a donut and you have a really
great gift that's it i gotta have a
donut
you know and they accrete they build up
after a while and then then one day you
go and there's no doughnut but you go
and you play a great show anyway oh
maybe it's not the donut
you know and so you you pick up and you
lose singers particularly because you
know drummer you break something you
play through it
singer your voice goes and it goes quite
easily it's quite a delicate instrument
and when it goes you are so screwed
um
and so
singers particularly have rituals of the
steam the humidity in the room
the there's the the humidifier you
breathe into in the throat coat and the
la la la la la la la la la la la la meme
and so the singers have a lot of rituals
so did you have what was your magic
donut did you have my magic done
well for years i i didn't have any magic
donut uh and then i realized that wow
you can actually go on feeling the way
you do on the third song when you're
warmed up and you kill you know the
first few songs just aren't as good
unless
you warm up
my god what a difference and i saw
um
i was actually at a with stanley clark
with some jazz musicians and the other
jazz musicians one of the drummers
famous guy was
doing his rudiments
and i'm thinking that's someone i
wouldn't be caught dead
you know publicly doing rudiments
[ __ ] you know but there was this jazz
cat doing it then he went out and his
first song was just like he'd been
playing all night
and so i without anybody noticing
started to do my rudiments and then i
noticed actually that stretching is even
better than rudiments all these muscles
in here all these tiny little muscles
the reason they play better three songs
in is because they're warmed up blood
circulating and it's just physics
biology and physics and so i have
rituals of stretching and so on and
each finger gets love and attention
because this finger here actually goes
up through to there and i can feel
that one's thank you and uh that you
know so all the
the the the stretching rituals that's
that's my particular poison
have there been particular
dark periods or difficult periods but if
going up to
the end of the police era
well the police itself was hell
just kidding
no i'm not kidding
no it was both it was like a prada suit
made out of barbed wire
it was incredible to have that effect on
audiences to
get on stage and do what we did was
darned exciting
but it became more and more difficult
for us to resolve our
creative differences and they come from
an honest place
um you know in the early days songs
would come into the band with just some
chords and we'd say oh cool let's play
that and let's mess around with it and
the writer of said song would be oh
really you like my song you want to play
it oh wow guys cool can i make tea you
know
after you've had written a few hits
that humility uh turns into something
else it turns into confidence
so
the vision of where to take the band
began to
not be quite so symmetrical and we uh
you know i saw the band like this stingo
saw it like that
and andy just saw great they're fighting
again
and he would he would just sort of he'd
pull up a dexter and throw bombs you
know
and if you are a true creative musician
you you don't show up to the studio at
that time he was he wasn't none of us
were showing up with a couple ideas and
then the band would develop it
we would all show up we all had home
recording studios now and we would show
up with platinum demos having thought
through every aspect of the song having
thought through not just what i'm going
to do but what he's going to do he's
going to here's your guitar part
and uh no no no no i've already written
the guitar part so play what i already
wrote since i wrote the song that's the
guitar part that i wrote so play that
and that you know we all felt that way
about because music's really important
to us it's really important that this
song i have conceived this song and it
should be expressed like that what do
you mean you've got another idea that
isn't this
go away with so that caused conflict it
was never an ego clash when
sting would get the attention and his
face on the cover that's a good day
because
you know we the band
he's our guy he's our face and you know
i love that but the music part was it
just got to be such a struggle of you
know
i want to express something in this band
but i can't because the door is locked
because he wrote the song and he's
decided how it's going to be by the way
the decisions that he had made
also including the drum part
were pretty good decisions actually the
guy really does know music and he really
does
he has impeccable producing chops that's
where the conflict came from
even as i understood
that
you know he comes turns around and he
says you know stewart you know that that
snare down there just turn it use the
rimshot [ __ ] off
and it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
this is an important point it doesn't
matter that actually
he was right about that snare drum thing
that that's actually kind of a cool idea
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
but when you're young you're right all
this wisdom by the way came decades
later
you know
he's
deep and
quiet i am noisy and shallow
we clash
um
we because of our history get along
really well and with mutual admiration
you know we really have a deep bond that
is just not breakable
after rehearsal we me you know we have
dinner together we laugh and we hang out
and and it's it's fine but man the music
thing and this is the reason i'm going
on because it's so weird it makes no
sense that we created such important
music that so many people
kind of liked
and yet
it came from
forcing together these elements that are
disparate
so the
question i'd love to ask is when you
have a bad day or an a down day
how does that manifest itself because
you're a passionate guy is it is it
anger is it
depression anxiety what is the
cocktail well anger is dope anger is
dope it is it feels good oh dope yeah
got it okay sorry it feels good
yeah
few things are more
invigorating than a nice
swelling of righteous anger
you know
uh sometimes i wake up in the morning
i'm in the shower when the blood the
brain chemistry is just bad
and i'm looking for someone to pick a
fight with somebody on tv
a politician my poor wife who's about to
come into the room you know and it's
brain chemistry and just it you know and
i'll get into some fantasy of who
somebody said this and then i said that
and then they said this and then i said
that
you know and you know the great part of
these anger fantasies is that you win
every argument
you just totally crush
and but then i i have breakfast i get
down to work i turn on my computer and
i'm still kind of
but then i get into work and i find that
on the day and this isn't every morning
by the way just some mornings you wake
up you know
and
i find that after morning like that
that i have a very serene day
go figure so you've sort of
prodded the monkey mind with a little
barbie yeah what is that it's gotten all
of it well the weird thing is the anger
the physical sensation of anger
is very pleasant
yeah especially when there's nothing to
be angry about
especially when the anger
it derives from an imaginary
conversation that never took place yeah
that is a
rarefied purified distilled anger that
just is a warm glow
all right so not everybody else has that
anger and after breakfast they're like
ah so
[Laughter]
did you have did you learn to turn it
down or turn it off or was it just it
ends out of the shower and you're like
it goes away it goes oh thank god i mean
you know
two things that cause bad decisions are
anger and sex
you know how many people have made just
stupid stupid stupid stupid stupid you
know that seemed like a really great
idea when i
was really mad or you know was at the
disco or whatever you know when i've
been listening to that music and
thrusting my pudenda one thing leads to
another
you know
that music yeah music causes bad
decisions
and anger's the same you know it seemed
like a really good idea to tell him what
i thought yeah it wasn't a good idea
yeah and best have those um
you know those moments in the shower
what are some of the decisions that have
formed who you are today if you look
back at some of the most important
decisions
well
some of the things good that happened
were because that was my mission but
other incredibly good thing happened
good things happened that were not on my
radar
i didn't expect
uh francis coppola to call up
and offer me a 20-year career basically
it ended up in film composing i you know
that wasn't my plan at all
but i found myself in that world and
just like thrived in it and
i didn't make that decision francis did
you know gave me my first shot and it
turned into something so some things you
strive for and you reach out for and you
go for
but some things just kind of come and
you know i would say as a piece of
advice
just stick to the answer yes
you know
orchestra in iceland in norway
you want to come over and play we have a
iceland
duet that you know
yes
i go over there i have the best time in
stavanger
i hadn't heard of it either
but this orchestra was fantastic that
just you know i discovered anchovies you
know i mean uh sardines you know and and
cured and olive oil and i have one can a
day now i mean so much good stuff
derived from just saying yes i didn't
know these guys i don't know what's
gonna happen but i've never been to
norway yes
the you know yes good things can come
from yes so francis ford coppola let's
talk about this this was correct from
wrong 1983.
i'll take your word for so rumblefish
where were you what did you think you
would be doing
say a year hence if if rumblefish had
not intervened
well
i would have gone mad
i recorded rumblefish right after
i think it was
the last or the second the last police
that my k it we came straight from
montserrat to the hell
of the police experience you know to go
into a studio with francis who's not a
musician he's the boss and i serving his
artistic vision but when he leaves the
room all the music is mine all the music
and no debating just like follow the
instincts and create something that's
beautiful without any debate oh
gosh that was fun
so there are many people out there who
score
films and so on
why didn't he go to one of the usual
suspects why did he why did he pick you
good question um he wanted to do
something out of the ordinary and in
fact he assembled a bunch of musicians
in tulsa oklahoma where they were
rehearsing the movie and there were
various musicians there and something
that i had learned at most a drummer
where the deal is you got to get the
other guy off the stool so you can take
his job
uh and in punk rock you know and i
pretty much just nuked all the
competition uh there were no survivors
but me
how did you nuke them yeah was this like
a false flag we're going to have a
well i got a studio i got into a studio
and while the others would talk about
what they're going to do
i got into a studio and recorded some
stuff
and um
i guess that's what it was beat them to
the i just beat them you know you know
like with band leadership or any kind of
leadership it's not about being given
some chevrons it's about having the best
idea first that's a leader
when
i got an idea let's do it like this and
you're the person with the idea which is
the best
people follow because they're relieved
that somebody had a fix for this
situation and so i just had the best
idea first in the opinion of the boss
man
when you think of the word
or hear the word successful who's the
first person or thing that comes to mind
it can be a tricky term i mean a lot of
people chase
this specter yes and they end up in a
place that is worse than where they
started in some cases or they've
sacrificed everything along the way what
is success to you and how has it changed
over over time i think the only measure
is happiness
you know
you can achieve what you thought was was
you know
and in my case happiness comes from my
family my kids you know i've got grammys
i
you know you get a grammy
you know you look at it you know for the
first couple of days it fills you ah man
man and then he goes to your shelf and
a week later you walk by go
and then a month later you walk by and
uh oh yeah
and then a year later you don't even see
it it just doesn't mean anything and so
all those things that you think are
success
they lose their thing
the kids the family your relationships
your life
are so you know
so i'm gonna uh go to some audience
questions and we have a number of them
do you have any advice for someone who
wants to pursue film scoring coming from
a rock and roll musical background
it's a very tough world to get into
because there are so many who want to be
there
and the dreams that take you to rock and
roll are very different from the dreams
of a film composer and you're you're
you're
developing you're working on the
director's artistic vision which means
that you are there to serve his
emotional needs and it's very different
mindset and many rock and rollers get
into the film composing and the director
says i'm just not feeling i wanted happy
sad and this is sad happy
and uh and and i don't like it do
something else
you know
the hardened wizard flinty-eyed film
composer says
throw that away i got more and you do by
the way you do have more you can throw
out your children and come up with
another idea and in fact
after a few years of film composing you
get pretty confident about that and you
can shed you don't like that it's gone
you'll never hear it again i'll come up
with something else and you can
and
that's really surprising how much stuff
is in your brain
that you can pull out when you need to
let me digress for a second here i've
done lots of episodic tv where the show
comes in tuesday i gotta ship it friday
next tuesday another show i got it it
may not be my finest hour but i got to
put something on tape and it's going out
the door and you just get into this
grind and you would think you run out of
ideas that you're going to get stale oh
my god i you know i'm used the opposite
happens
you got to deal with that
and i'm here to tell you you can
but that's that's a tough threshold to
cross
next one is the music industry has
changed so much since when you started
what advice besides the never-ending
hustle would you give a budding musician
today
i guess the only advice that i can give
you would be creatively how to find your
own sound and urge you above all
artistically to to get a unique sound
look for different sources of
inspiration
somehow set yourself apart from other
artists by just different sources you
know different stuff in different stuff
out is my philosophy but how you crack
the business
you probably know more about that than i
do
because you've been in this business for
the last 10 minutes not the decades
before that
and uh i think also i don't have the the
music experience but it seems like the
barrier to produce music is lower you
have this yeah that's good news but the
barrier to attention is higher because
you're going to have more competition
due to
the aforementioned low buried production
so a few things that have helped at
least in the startup world quite a lot
where you have a very similar issue
where now you have rental rentable
infrastructure
that before would have cost five hundred
thousand dollars
uh i would recommend checking out one
thousand true fans it's an essay by guy
named kevin kelly which i think is very
good there's a revised version coming
out very soon
and also the law of category it's a
chapter in a book called the 22
immutable laws of marketing but it talks
about exactly what you just mentioned
which is
being
a
clear and distinct category compared to
whatever you are competing against
and sort of creating a blue ocean in
that respect so those two have been very
helpful at least in the startup world
which i think at this point in time a
lot of musicians
breaking through that attention barrier
would be well served to start thinking
of the at least the band not necessarily
the music as their own startup in a
sense
next question just
one more thing about that artistic
identity don't be fearful
if your music doesn't sound like
everything else on the radio
and
don't be
complacent if it does
this sounds just like
beyonce
that's when you got to be worried
[Laughter]
yeah hard to out beyonce beyonce
uh
the next question is from facebook this
is from aung jab
which i like
uh what interests you musically now
uh
well input these days is my own radio
station i listened to it's called it's
uh it's on itunes uh it's called shirley
and spinosa i have nothing to do with it
but i can't shout its name loudly enough
it is the best radio station ever it
is so eclectic
one minute they'll be playing beach boys
the next minute you know uh
uh armenian chants the next one is the
name of it again uh shirley
s-h-i-r-l-e-y and spinoza it's just the
name right there it's the mix and match
and sometimes i'm listening to as i'm
roadieing in the studio is that even
music it's like white noise and then
they've got a weird 50s cigarette
commercial playing over it and then
and then it goes to country and western
some you know okie from muskogee it's
like everything that
is the best that's the input right there
and another source is driving my 16 year
old to school
i have been forced to admit that kanye
is a genius
now
you know
my cultural environment
has only exposed me to kanye grabbing
someone else's grammy
you know that's all i know about him
until i start hearing his music and him
and the black-eyed peas and you know
ocean and uh
uh kamar uh kendrick lamar lamar
kendrick uh
all of my friends who don't have a
sixteen-year-old daughter you know i
actually haven't listened to this stuff
go oh that's not music where's that
there's no backfeed
they don't even have guitars
they sound like my dad
you know and i listen to stuff and they
have just thrown away all the building
blocks that i grew up with but they
pushed the boundaries of the it sounds
like the soundtrack to a really strange
movie
and you know and these are hits and they
finally
since
chuck berry and bill haley
invented the guitar bass and drums combo
you know and my father that was the
enemy that's not music and there was
that divide my dad listened to trumpets
and saxophones i listened to long-haired
music with and that same music
hasn't changed through
all the the 60s the 70s the 80s the 90s
punk is still e a and d chords with a
back beat
whatever it's a backbeat whether it's
funk or rock or whatever it's the same
building blocks
until kendrick
and these guys just throw out all those
ingredients and start again and driving
on my daughter to school in the morning
hearing this stuff i don't that's the
first time i'm hearing music i i
wouldn't know how to make that
the all right let's let's go this one
and i'll explain what i mean do you have
a favorite failure and what i mean by
that is a failure that in retrospect set
you up for a later success great uh i
i'm stumped to think of a particular one
but this has been a motif
that i keep coming back to
that a disappointment something goes bad
something's wrong something's broken
creates an opportunity
and i screwed this up and because i
screwed this up i'm in this position
here
and since i'm in this visit this
opportunity arises
and that is a recurring theme and i wish
i could think of a great example for you
but but it just is that sometimes a door
that closes is a window that's opening a
a glass that breaks is a
something
and
yeah i mean interrupt you
that's pretty much the way i'm feeling
about america right now
if you had a gigantic billboard you
could put anything on it and you had a
few words short message you just wanted
to get out to the world it's gonna
another one of those questions uh what
would you put on it
don't worry be happy
and that's a total cop-out riding home
this afternoon i'm gonna come up with it
well let's let's put it a different way
so we have we have a lot of people in
the audience here we have a lot of
people
watching who are maybe
inspired to take
the next step in a new chapter they're
probably nervous they might have some
misgivings they might be leaving
something behind who knows
but for someone who is striking out
attempting something new
what would your
parting thoughts advice recommendation
be
i would say that obsess over every
mining detail of what success looks like
and imagine you know
i believe that a daydream is a very
useful exercise and when i was a kid i'd
daydream
and if it's a really good daydream then
you fill in the gaps if you keep going
back to what you really really want
you go back to that daydream and every
time you go back to you fill in the
things and eventually that daydream
starts to flesh out into an actual game
plan
and so
that you know it's good to daydream and
so thinking thinking thinking
overthinking don't be scared to
overthink but when it comes to throw the
switch just do it baby and don't be
thinking anymore and don't let any of
the thinking slow you down just be in a
position where you have thought of
everything but don't let any of that
slow you down just throw the switch leap
off the cliff yeah baby let's go
and that's how you do it
ladies and gentlemen stuart girlblade
thank you
thank you folks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you